I just and you pulled a little prank on  our vice president Mike Pence is that  right oh I did you want to tell us what  that was all about this is when a lot of  hate mail comes my way I apologize if  I'm offending anybody it's not so much a  prank as much as I disagreed with some  of the stuff that pence was doing and I  was trying to do and so as a reminder  that there are women out there in the  world that may or may not agree with his  platform I put him on a list of  reoccurring donations that are made in  his name to Planned Parenthood and so  this happens every month every month to  his office he gets a little letter that  says like a doe an anonymous donation  has been made in your name I don't look  at it as if I don't look at as a prank  I literally this is just like I strongly  disagree and this is my little way of  peaceful protest yeah it's a peaceful  protest  exactly  you